the american president used prime time
for a hastily arranged white house
address
flanked down the corridor by a candle
for each of the 56 states and
territories of this nation because this
gun violence has touched every corner
for god's sake
how much more carnage are we willing to
accept
how many more innocent american lives
must be taken before we say enough
enough
this year alone there have been 234 mass
shootings in america that's 10 a week
this among the latest a hospital in
tulsa oklahoma two doctors a patient and
a receptionist dead
shot by a man who'd bought his
semi-automatic weapon just hours earlier
we need to ban assault weapons in
high-capacity magazines
and if we can't ban assault weapons then
we should raise the aids to purchase
them from 18 to 21.
the president was in uvalde texas a few
days ago he felt the pain of 19 sets of
parents and the survivors
imagine being that little girl that
brave little girl in uvalde
who smeared blood off her murdered
friend's body on her own face
to lie still among the corpses in her
classroom and pretend she was dead in
order to stay alive
all this horror has stirred something in
new york after the shooting in buffalo
local politicians have changed state law
semi-automatic weapons will now only be
available to over 21s and with a license
and in washington on capitol hill
they're debating new laws now but listen
to those taking part in the debates it
doesn't fit so this gun would be banned
i hope the gun is not loaded
i'm at my house i can do whatever i want
with my guns
the calls for change come every time and
yet this uniquely american cycle of gun
violence goes on and on
mark stone sky news in washington